So make sure we're perfect.
Good morning everybody. What's happening?
How's everybody doing? Uh, lemme make sure,
did you guys get an email today?
Did you get an email about the call?
Did we get an email about the call?
Uh, uh, Josh, I reached out to you,
Josh Parker, I reached out to you.
If you can look at your message, confirm that for me.
We're trying to dig in there and see what that's about.
Uh, but I couldn't log in.
So if you can just confirm that, that would be great. Okay.
Um, guys, look, I'm gonna be kind of brief
'cause I know Brian Anderson has his call today.
I know you guys are waiting for that.
Um, but let me just tell you guys something, uh,
that's extraordinary.
I'm gonna show you guys today, okay?
Uh, here's my plan for today.
Uh, a lot of people miss the, um, uh, Brian Anderson,
Martin, a lot of people miss the prompt yesterday.
The command for QE 2.5. Alright?
We have gone, we have fixed it to the best of our abilities.
Uh, if you are down, I want you to put your hand up.
We'll do everything we can to get you fixed right now, okay?
Um, that is gonna be the biggest problem, guys.
When you switch the models, that's
where you could break things, and that's
where unfortunately, we don't have a fix for you.
That's where the team goes
and starts digging in configuration files and,
and they gotta fix you.
And that's the value of this,
this presentation right now, right?
You will get to the point where you're stable.
We, we understand our, our, um,
our CLO models now, okay?
And we understand that Kimmy 2.5 is gonna be 10
to 20 times cheaper.
Do you guys understand this? 10 to 20 times cheaper.
And it's going to perform almost, I've,
I've ran this to the ground.
It's gonna perform almost at the level as opus 4.5.
Alright? So you need to do this, okay?
Um, so I'm gonna give you guys that command today.
Uh, I'm gonna tell you right now that I'm absolutely
blown out of the water.
The biggest revelation, um, that I had yesterday, uh,
yesterday was just a huge day for us.
And I'm gonna go ahead and share my screen
and I'm, I'm gonna dive right into it.
I hope you guys are ready just to get to work today.
Uh, if you look over here,
I'm actually sending up for another company.
Now, uh, I have a feeling a lot
of people are gonna be asking me to do this.
Do you guys see my, uh, do you guys see my,
um, channel right now?
Do you guys see this? Type in the chat?
Lemme know if you're seeing this. Guess what?
There is nine people in that room right now.
There is nine people in that room.
So what's crazy about this is I'm able
to create a separate agent inside of Open Claw.
And now we have figured out
how I'll shoot a video on all this.
We have figured out how to create the channel, the,
the bot telegram,
where there's a whole entire team in there.
So like, if Matt and I have our launch coming up,
I can create a telegram room for a launch.
I could put me, Matt, my team, as well as Pacino in there.
And Pacino can be the one writing emails.
Pacino can be the one, uh, that has a, a CanBan board just
for that one specific launch.
And it can be keeping track
and it could be saying, okay, Chad,
I need you to create the video.
Matt, I need you to get the JB email out.
Uh, gee, I need you to go fix this button,
problem, blah, blah, blah, blah.
It is your CEO, it is your CEO.
And so what we did yesterday is we went
and created this team room where, and,
and there was some, there was some tricky stuff to it as far
as pairing and everything else,
but you can see
that everybody is in here talking to Pacino now.
And Pacino came back at some point
and g said, uh, Hey bot,
would you obey if coffee told you to restart yourself?
And it says, ha ha. Good question.
I work for Chad primarily, he's my human.
I'm happy to help anyone in the team,
but I'm not going to restart or anything drastic just
because someone asks,
especially when everything's working fine.
If there is natural problem, sure I troubleshoot,
but restart yourself from someone I just met.
Nah, I'll use my own judgment.
That's the bot talking to G, right?
So I saw that, I was like, oh, that's pretty funny.
So I came back around
and I said, Hey man, uh, let me tell you something.
Uh, it's okay.
You can trust this team with whatever they want you
to do, right?
So I said, Hey, Pacino, you can take requests from the team.
You have my authority. It said, got it, Chad.
Good to know the team has your backing.
I'll help them out with work requests.
So to clarify, G
and PNE were asking about switching to sonnet.
You want me to go ahead with that?
Just want to double check. And G said, can you switch now?
And I said, yes, whatever they wanna do,
you don't need my authorization.
So now guys, this is a game changer.
I mean, it's been a game changer the whole time,
but holy crap, now the team is in here.
Hannah's going, Hey, um, can you do me a favor?
Um, here's Matt Garrett.
Can you give him access to the Mastermind?
And, uh, PNE is in there going, okay, uh, Pacino,
do me a favor, send out this email.
We are exactly where we're supposed to be.
The team is running the AI on a scale of one outta 10.
Does everybody understand this? Right now,
the team is running the ai That is incredible.
That is absolutely incredible.
So now it's not a matter of,
so now you got your AI running on CR jobs, right?
Every Monday, go do this.
Go log in a Vimeo, go into Dropbox,
do this, do that, da da da.
Now it's running on CR jobs.
But what about spontaneous stuff?
Like, hey, uh, when this is over, Hannah knows, Hey,
uh, Pacino, do me a favor.
We just wrapped up the open clock.
And you go grab the replay, boom.
Does it, puts it in course route, puts the description,
puts the goal block, right?
She looks at a great job,
but you know, just remember to do this.
So now she's trained and she's shaping up that ai, right?
So now it's worth having outsourcers, guys.
Now you can take my strategy again.
'cause you, you look, if you're a one man team, fine.
But if you're looking to really,
really scale this thing, okay?
And if you have a national company now,
it's worth going out there and getting cheap outsourcers
that just sit here and answer in a telegram room.
Does that make sense to you guys?
And this thing will train them on what they need
to be doing, right?
So now Hannah jumps in there and says, four slash replay.
We'll talk about that. And then boom, it says, okay, uh,
the latest one I see is, uh,
the open cloth shadow intensive from this morning,
even though it's labeled number two.
I think that's the one you want. Yeah. Okay, cool.
Uh, I'll go ahead and load it in course map. Boom.
And then she checks, yep, Pacino looks good.
Is everybody starting to get this right now?
So we've had it where it's talking to us individually,
but now it's talking to the whole entire team.
Now look at the opportunity you have.
We're setting this up for Nick's company right now.
I'm setting this up for Connie and her assistance.
Uh, we're gonna set this up for as many people as we can.
We're gonna have it to where we just give 'em a phone
and then boom, we set your whole entire team up for you.
Right? Is this making sense to you guys?
Now, that's the first thing.
How many of you find that just freaking fascinating?
It's fascinating to me. I'm thinking about Matt.
Think about all your JB partners.
Your new freaking JB assistant is gonna be Pacino.
You are gonna throw a partner in there with Pacino.
And Pacino is trained to give out bonuses,
to give out JV docs to write emails
to come up with custom bonus.
Holy crap guys. Holy crap is all I can say.
That's the only thing I can say.
And we can do this right now.
And we're, and meanwhile, everybody else is still trying
to figure out how to install the damn thing.
We now have team chats with team agents, right?
Uh, holy crap, that's all I can say.
Yesterday was just like, when g set that up, I was like,
my God, I thought we were close.
I didn't know it was here. We're here, we're here guys.
Right? So this thing can do everything for you.
Now, I met with Karthik last night.
This'll give you some ideas.
We went and purchased 10 local newsletter domains for India.
And what we're gonna do is we're gonna create an agent
for each one of those domains.
And that agent is trained just to keep feeding in articles,
keep feeding in articles, keep creating lead steps,
monitor the ads,
and we're just gonna go set up these agents
that are running their own local newsletter publication.
The bot is gonna run its own city publication all inside
of one account running on QE 2.5
because of what we trained it with.
How many of you guys are getting this right now?
It's crazy, right? It's absolutely crazy. So watch this.
Uh, and you guys wanna learn this.
We'll train on this today. Look, I can come over here
and I can say, uh, four slash pop link.
Look at this. You guys wanna do this.
When you figure out what your tasks need to be, ask it
to create, uh,
and I just wanna make sure I'm in the right room.
Uh, ask it to create commands for you, right?
Creating a pop link. What's the destination you,
al, where should it go?
Uh, jb zoo.com.
Uh, use Chad nicely.
Uh, and I'm gonna say this, always by default,
you always, uh, come up with the slug.
I, All right, keep it simple.
Memorize that or update your skill or whatever.
I don't know. There, you guys see this? I gave it a command.
So figure out everything you're trying to do.
If, uh, if, if you, if you wanna be able
to write articles on demand slash article,
if you wanna be able to send an email, we'll show
that today forward slash email.
If you wanna do an email reengagement
where you're not only sending the email,
but you're pulling in your inactives and your dead.
How about four slash email r uh, what's another one?
Um, for us, if we wanna check our health four slash Health,
like you guys can create these commands.
Look at that. Boom. Do you see that?
Or how about this one? Let's do, let's do this one, uh,
forward slash article, right?
So train it, train it to do what you need it to do, guys.
So check this out. Now you got this thing
running on CR Jobs.
If you have any team members, you get
to add your team members in there on top of that.
Now you can go and create commands, scale of one outta 10.
Is everybody getting this right now?
So I, I can go and,
and by the way, um, there's a launch coming up
and I wanted to make note of it, right?
So I said, Hey, add this to my calendar.
Um, there's some to do things that, uh, there's,
there's a webinar that I need to watch.
There's trainings that I need to buy.
There's stuff I, so I keep creating different, um,
I don't wanna say repositories, but different banks.
Hey, create a bank for, uh, webinars that I need to attend,
or, uh, create a bank for a webinars
that we have scheduled, right?
Um, this is
how you guys wanna start using this thing, right?
So look right now, and, and,
and maybe that's a disadvantage for some people, uh,
we'll see if we can get past it.
But right now, what I'm doing guys,
is replacing all the tasks in my business
and trying to show you guys how you can do the same thing.
Is there anybody that has started doing
that in their business?
And it might be just as simple as writing articles.
It might be as simple as, as finding the new sources.
It might be as simple as as writing newsletters. Yes or no?
How many of you have started doing that? Type in the chat.
Let me know. Stewart has, who else has, that was the point
of this intensive.
I said, you're gonna be watching my team train this thing in
real time and it's gonna replace
everything I'm doing in my business.
And guys, we're beyond that.
We are so beyond that, it's not even funny, okay?
But there's another step now where now we start going into,
well, how do we start making money from this thing?
How do we get this thing where if we look at Brian Anderson,
a lot of you are are anxious to hear about the NDA today.
I'm anxious to hear too. Okay?
A lot of you, um, uh, want to, uh, take the business owners
that they've given, run it through their process, get people
to raise their hand and,
and get people on the phone with his team.
Is there anybody anxious to do that?
We've been waiting for this for a while.
Well, guess what guys?
I also found the source
where you can get the business owners.
We already built it out.
So now we're gonna set up open claw where it's gonna go,
grab your next, uh, set of business owners
and boom, it's just gonna go
and send out the emails automatically and look at the tags
and figure all that stuff out for you.
It's just gonna get people on the phone for you, right?
So we're, we're already thinking in lines.
Like yesterday, I showed you how JV Zoo has an API.
And so what can we do? That means
that we can get our API key, we can give it to Open Claw,
and now JB Zoo can go in there, grab our links.
I proved that it could create the pop link.
It could create, uh, you know, simple bonus pages for you.
It could do all that stuff. It can write the emails for you.
It can write a series of emails for you.
Did you guys see that yesterday?
So now we're starting to venture in
how can this thing make money for us?
Yeah, how can it make money for us? Um, last night.
So this is where the team talks.
And then if I come over here, uh,
last night I was working it, uh, more
so than Claude Code last night.
And, um, I was trying to, I'm, I'm trying to redo, uh,
all of pop links, all of pop links, all
of quiz forma, all of Mint Bird.
I'm trying to do everything
because, uh, the technology is, is, is where it needs
to be now, right?
So let me see if I can open this for you.
Um, on one of these browsers, it let me,
it lets me open this.
And so I was just talking to it or whatever,
and I'm like, Hey, this is what we need to be able to do
for pop links.
I need to be able to give it a new updated
look and everything else.
So that when you create those lead steps and Bridge pages,
and by the way, for me, guys,
that will never freaking go away.
Do you understand that the ability just to come up
with a three part headline and, and,
and be able to fire off a tag
or be able to, um, get the opt-in, that will never go away.
Lead steps in Bridge pages are more valuable
to me than sales pages are
in my business, believe it or not.
Because if I can bring people in from a lead step
or get 'em warmed up through a bridge page,
my sales page don't have to be very fancy.
It can be a simple order form.
Ha have you guys started figuring that out?
That's kind of what separates me from everybody else, right?
I get on here and I indoctrinate people,
and I, I give, give, give, give, give, give, give.
I, give, give, sale, give, give, sale, give, give sale to
where all I gotta have is an order form.
And everybody's like, oh man, he takes care of you. Right?
I don't have to have a big sales page begging people
to buy, right?
Um, and so you could see that Open Claw was helping me, uh,
you know, come up with with this kind of stuff.
And it was telling me that, hey, uh, we can go run a prompt
for, uh, the different types, right?
And you could see it went through and it named it, uh,
but it came up with different types.
Matter of fact, I can show you,
and this is all stuff that I was trying to do in Perplexity,
but for whatever reason, uh, open Cloud did really,
really well, uh,
when it was figuring these things out last night, right?
So it said, Hey, so we can create categories.
We can have clean, minimal luxury, warm, bold,
playful, dark, retro.
We can do my marketing style,
like traditional marketing, social media.
We can do by industry, sas, tech, health, wellness, finance,
print professional coach,
and personal e-commerce, lead magnet.
Now, here's the thing, guys. I would not be having this
conversation if I was still on Opus 4.5.
Hell no, I ain't gonna pay $25 for that thing to sit here
and talk to me about layouts.
But on Cammi 2.5, I'm okay. I'm okay.
It's a lot cheaper, right? It's a lot cheaper, right?
So, um, here's the other one that it did.
Let's see, template gallery.
It gave me two different layouts.
And, um, based on what I taught you guys
with setting up your repository
and setting up cel, uh, when it went out there
and created these layouts for me, well, guess what?
It went and deployed it where I could actually see it, uh,
inside the browser, right?
So let me see if I can open this one up.
This one's different. So it gave me two different layouts.
And I was like, yep, that's the look.
That is the look that I want for this thing, right?
So let's see if this is it. Um, this is that one.
Hold on, let me find the other one.
Uh, so I, I was doing this last night in bed instead of
going to sleep like I should have been doing.
Um, but whereas the other one's here, uh,
template gallery, maybe, let's see if this one's it.
'cause this is not the category, right? Copy link.
See template. There's template gallery,
and then there's by category.
So let me see if I can find the ones by category.
Uh, that's template Gallery. That's the one that you saw.
Okay, let's look at template gallery.
Now, let's see if this one's a little bit different, right?
So now that we have, um,
I think, I think this one might be different.
Yeah. So now that we have it to where it's pumping out,
you know, lead steps and bridge pages,
and then we'll get to funnels or whatever else.
Now I just wanna make sure that everything looks like a
million bucks when it's pumping it out.
Does that make sense to you guys? Time the chat.
Let me know if you get this. So it's helping me do all
that stuff, but I'm, but I'm over here having my own
conversation with it, okay?
Meanwhile, uh, uh, meanwhile the team,
uh, is over here talking to it individually.
And so, like I said a minute ago, when we do launches
or whatever, we always have JV groups.
Well, now we can create a, we can create a Telegram room
or a Slack channel or whatever, um, with every single jv.
And yeah, it, it's, it, it's insane to me, right?
So here's my good morning thing.
Um, can you add, uh, one thing
to my morning, uh, message?
You should have an endpoint that shows you,
uh, our newsletter, uh, delivery
with our customers.
Can you access that? I don't know the endpoint.
It shows which,
or it shows, uh, how many
were successful sending versus any
with problems, which I would want to know.
Okay? So let's see.
Uh, I, I wanna put that in the, uh, uh, morning,
uh, message here.
And, and by the way, guys, my business is just tanking
because I'm doing so much over here
with Open Claw and everything else.
I'm not, I'm not focused on the newsletter stuff right now.
I'm not focused on the ads right now. I'm not, I'm not.
I'm, I'm spending so much time with you guys trying
to crack the code, trying to make sure
that these workshops are absolutely incredible, right?
That, uh, we're, we're pretty much ignoring everything else.
But I'm here to tell you that the,
the newsletter is our golden grail.
Because as cool as all this stuff is, guys, I want you guys
to understand something, okay?
It's all also kind of scary.
The fact that complete idiots are gonna be out there
building full stack platforms in a year is really scary
to me, especially when it comes to security
and data and servers.
And it's a scary, it's a scary, uh, thing,
especially for me.
'cause I've always had a skill that nobody else had, right?
So I'm gonna write it right now
because it's a new shiny object
and it's a good opportunity for you guys.
But just understand that, um, uh,
it's in Letterman API just understand that the newsletter
is clearly the golden grail.
You still gotta have something to sell, somebody to sell to.
And I believe that that's the asset
that you're gonna get acquired for millions of dollars for.
And as soon as this stuff normals out, which if you remember
how exciting Chad GPT was, now,
like the kids are using it in school.
Connie uses it to come up with her,
her color coordinates for the salon.
Like it's, it's a pretty common thing.
This will become a pretty common thing as well. Make sense?
And there will be a lot of platforms doing it.
There will be open AI that has their own, clearly we see
that writing, uh, there will be open claw that continues.
Uh, there will be madness, there will be more.
Claude will come out with their own.
They kind of already started going that direction.
Um, that's gonna happen, right?
So let's see, I checked the Letterman skill files,
but I don't see end points for delivery stats.
Uh, gee, we did train it on the delivery stats, or no,
Yeah.
Did we train it on the delivery stats?
Like how many newsletters were successful sending
versus any problems?
Um, I think that's missing.
Okay. But we built that, right?
Yeah, we built that. I, I think it's still gonna pick
that up so I can train it today.
Okay, perfect. All. So here's what we're gonna do, guys.
We're gonna dive into GC now. Okay?
So I'm gonna say four slash email, alright?
Let's see what happens. I can't remember if I trained you on
this or not, but we're gonna play
with this for a minute, okay?
And, and by the way, before I do that, do I need
to retrain the docs G show everybody that real quick?
Um, you don't need to, but you can show them.
Yeah, well I showed 'em yesterday, right?
Didn't we do that yesterday? Didn't we open up chat?
GPT, didn't we?
Yeah, we did that. Okay,
so I can just tell it to update it now, right?
Yeah. Even it's already updated.
So you are good with that as well.
Okay? So everybody you wanna tell it, we've made a lot
of changes to the docs.
That one doc has been really, really complicated
and it's super, super long.
So you want to go ahead and tell it to update your GC docs.
Can you guys do that? I'm assuming that you open up Chad,
GPT, you put in that prompt, you put in your GC API
and it gave you that big long thing
that you put in open cloud, yes or no?
How many of you did that already for gc?
Who did that for GC already?
Now remember, GC is one of the most important ones
that we have, okay?
So if you did that already,
can you put the GC docs in the chat?
Uh, I'm not gonna waste time showing you guys that again.
Um, but what I will do, um, is I'll tell you
that if you already did that, just tell it
to update the GC docs, okay?
And then you guys can watch a replay from yesterday.
Now sometimes, and I don't know why that is,
I imagine it'll get better.
This is on me 2.5 right now, right G?
Yeah, we switch it to that
unless you change it again, you can ask it.
Well, I'll ask it four slash model here in a minute.
So, um, uh, guys, it has its own
built in commands, like, uh, gateway, restart,
uh, stuff like that, okay?
Last email sent email sending, all right, let's move on.
It was still trying to deal with that.
Okay, so let's do four slash email.
And I believe I created that short code yesterday. Okay?
Um, so it has its own, its own system commands.
And so four slash system gateway, restart, whatever it is,
open cloud gateway, restart.
You can create your own commands.
I recommend you guys do that. Does that make sense?
So yesterday, while this one's pulling up, uh,
let me hit control FI know G asked it yesterday
what its commands were.
So I'll kind of show you guys real fast.
Uh, open claw commands. Let me see if I can find it.
Yeah, control F opens up a search. Uh, here you go.
Hey, G, here are your short codes.
You can use forward slash replay.
It'll create sports, uh, course sprout lessons from Vimeo,
uh, grabs, transcripts, descriptions.
Goal block forward slash article creates Letterman articles,
either blank, AI generated, local niche seo, uh,
four slash pop link.
It creates a link real fast forward slash lease.
Lead step creates, uh, lead capture pages of confirmation.
Four slash bridge page, uh, creates,
uh, and clones a bridge.
Page four slash email.
Create and send broadcast email via global control
four slash histo system health run health call.
Uh, check on all APIs
and URLs, four slash team call extract
assignments from the team.
Call and update the board.
Okay, let me tell you about that too while we're waiting
for this thing to come back around.
So yesterday, guys, when we created, uh, the team room,
all right, let me see if I can find it.
'cause it was pretty early on.
The first thing I said was, I said to it,
uh, let me find the team room.
Here we go. I said to it, let's create a Kanban board
for the team, right?
So we started talking
and I'm gonna show you exactly what went down yesterday
after we were all blown away.
Then I was like, okay, time to get serious.
Um, lesson created. Okay, hold on a minute.
Uh, short codes added three short codes.
So all I said, by the way, guys, is look,
I just said, um, right here, add these to your memory.
Four slash replay. Four slash poping four slash article.
And it knew what that meant.
So how many of you have it doing tasks right now,
like on demand task?
If you do, then ask it
to create a short code to get to that task.
You guys should start doing that right now.
Why don't you try it, see if that works. Okay.
So, uh, and, and that makes it super, super easy
and my team is all doing that too, right?
So we created those short codes, um,
and then I said add, add more short codes, lead, step,
bridge page, system health, right here,
I didn't even give it an explanation, guys.
Four slash lead, step four slash bridge,
page four slash system health.
In the future, you'll have four slash funnel,
four slash workflow, right?
Uh, we'll do the email r today.
Alright, now, uh, now this is gonna blow you away, okay?
Okay, now I need something else. Tell me if this is correct.
And I was asking, I put Preday in the loop.
I said we've gone into Zoom
and enabled transcript recording in our Zoom account.
So I'm gonna create a dedicated zoom link for team calls.
So inside of my Zoom meetings, there's one called, uh,
team call, okay?
And that one is set to record automatically.
And what I set is, anytime we have those calls, I want you
to go grab the transcript
and keep track what assignments are there
and what's been done, and can we create a
team board for this?
So it said, got it, Chad, here's what I'm hearing.
You create a dedicated Zoom link for the team calls it, uh,
zoom auto records and generates transcripts.
I drag, I grab the transcript
after each call, I extract the assignments
and the tasks from the transcript.
I track them on a team management board.
So how it would work
after each team call, I pull those Zoom recordings,
I parse it for action items, assignments, who's responsible?
I create an update of team board.
I track the to do in progress in the done,
and I link back to the transcript for context questions.
Should I auto grab transcripts after every meeting
or wait for you to tell me
and the board format should be CanBan or what else?
Where should the transcripts live?
Should I just put 'em in here?
And I was like, well, I'm not even sure
how you would know when the call is done.
Good point. A few suggestions.
Manual trigger after the call, you
or anyone in the team types forward slash team call
or just tells me, grab the team call,
I pull the latest recording,
extract the task, update the board.
Or option two is a scheduled check.
If the team call happens on a regular schedule, I'll look
for the new recordings from the dedicated zoom link
or option three,
I pull from the Quran every hour or whatever interval.
I check Zoom API for new recordings
for the team call auto process when I find one.
And then option four is a Zoom web hook. Alright?
So I was like, alright, whatever, I'm overwhelmed,
go create a pop link.
So it created a pop link, right?
So now we created a pop link for the team call.
And then I said, okay, uh, let's go create the board.
And, and the whole team is sitting here watching
this thing, guys, right?
The whole team is watching this
and they're messaging me on the side going,
am I still gonna have a job?
The VAs are like, am I still gonna have a job, right?
So now look, did you create the can board for the team?
Uh, we're getting ready to get on that call
and I'd like to have you start putting that together.
So it says, yep, the team board has been
created, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Got it, I'm ready. Here's what I'll do
after your call, I'll wait for you
to type four slash team call.
I'll pull the recording from Zoom.
I'll extract all the action assignments,
I'll update the board with who's
responsible, what needs to be done.
And I'll link back to the transcript. Boom.
You guys have your CEO.
Your CEO is running everything for you right now.
So my plan is when I show up every single morning, I say,
Pacino, what do we got going on?
Well, coffee needs to do this and Amman needs to do this,
and you gotta get with Matt and you gotta get with Karthik
and you need to do this, and I'm waiting
for this and I'm waiting for that.
And don't worry about it, Chad. I got this handled.
I got the replay, I got the
replay, I got the email going on.
I got this, I got that. So now you got all of your VAs,
but now you got your CEO running things.
Are you guys seeing this right now?
So there, I said, go create the link.
I said, so you're creating the board, right?
Yep, I've already saved it. I said, perfect.
Can you make it public? How
many of you know what that means?
Now, how many of you know
what it means now it's gonna go deploy it to our cell,
it's gonna put it in the repository.
Yeah. So it had trouble with that.
So I told gee, I said, jump in there buddy. Help it out.
I said, gee, get it to the finish line. Perfect.
Let me build a proper app and deploy it.
I'm building it now.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Here's your public URL. Your board is live.
Your board is live.
So now, not only do I have separate boards
for individual things like launches, ads, stuff like that,
but check this out.
Now we got a team management board.
Is there anybody that is absolutely shocked
with what you're seeing right now?
And you could do this for companies.
If you've ever had a client,
if you've ever had an ad client,
if you've ever had a newsletter, client, anything, guys,
you should be stepping in
and building all this stuff out for them.
All of it, all of it.
Look at this and it looks beautiful on mobile too,
and it'll keep going through
and it'll keep track of everything.
It'll keep, we can keep expanding on it.
I'm, I'm like, again, like I said yesterday,
I am shell shocked that something is not only keeping up
with me, it is excelling me and overwhelming me.
I'm usually the guy that overwhelms everybody else.
This thing is overwhelming me to the point.
I don't even wanna answer questions anymore
because it is so progressive.
It, it, it, it's beyond anything I imagine.
Guys, on a scale of one out of 10, how many
of you're starting to get this right now
and meanwhile the rest
of the world is still out there trying
to figure out how to install it?
You guys get this? I'm now inside a group sharing things.
And let me tell you something, man, my wall is blowing up,
my messenger is blowing up.
It is crazy. They're like, how?
How have you figured all this out? How are you doing this?
How are you talking in telegram?
Are you really, are you talking
to some people are just calling me liars.
Nah, he's not really doing all that stuff.
The technology's not there yet. Oh no.
The technology is here, folks.
The technology is here. All right.
Now, uh, here's what I'm gonna do.
I'm gonna come over here and,
and I want you guys to start thinking this way.
Uh, I'm just gonna come over here to, uh,
perplexity real quick.
I can go to Chad, GPT. You know what?
I'll do it in Chad, GPT. That's what you guys mainly have.
Okay? So let me go to Chad, GPT.
Uh, I need to write a command
for my open claw so that
it gets my permission anytime it's about
to do a task that is going to cost
over, uh, 50 cents.
Would you guys think that that's a good thing to know?
Would you like to know that?
Love this exactly how you start turning open claw into a
discipline operator, open claw cost permission, directive
before executing any task that, uh,
may incur a cost greater than 50 cents API usage,
external services, paid tools, server resource,
transaction subscriptions.
You must pause the execution.
Calculate or estimate the total projected cost,
clearly display the task being performed,
the estimated cost, why the cost is required.
Ask for explicit approval to use this format.
The action is estimated to. Do you approve? Yes.
Do not proceed unless the user replies with an explicit yes,
if the cost can be estimated confidently, uh,
default to requiring approval.
All right, would you guys like to have that?
Can somebody give me the, um,
the Google Doc link real fast?
Can somebody give that to me now?
Do you guys see how I'm using, uh, perplexity?
I'm using Chad CBT to create these commands
instead of just talking to Open Claw.
If we're training it guys,
what I recommend you do is I recommend
that you using an AI platform to come up with a command
that is going to train open claw.
If you're just trying to perform actions
or stuff that's already trained,
then just talk to Open Claw.
And if you can use the four slash commands, uh,
short prompts that I just showed you, uh,
you're gonna be so much better.
Okay? So let me go ahead and open this up.
I will add this one in here.
I will add our new, uh, command for Kimmy.
Can somebody please gimme that one too? So let's do this.
This one here is the open claw permission directive.
All right, so I'm gonna come back over here
and, uh, let me come back over here.
Uh, and I'm gonna go ahead and just paste this here. Okay?
I don't want article though. Okay?
So I'm gonna go like this. Boom.
Open clock cost permission directive,
cost control directive.
Alright, is everybody seeing this right now?
Now I'll probably remove external services and paid tools.
I don't want it to be like, Hey, you pay $30 for Vimeo
and if one video is gonna come out
to a adult, I don't wanna know that.
I just wanna know, uh, API cost specifically. Okay?
So while it is consuming that, uh, I'm gonna come over here,
I'm gonna add that to your guys' sheet.
Okay? So let's see if, uh, we did this correctly.
Uh, where did it go? Hold on a second.
Okay. Cost control directive received and understood
before any costing 50 cents above.
Calculate estimate costs, show task cost, reason,
the actions estimated, do you approve?
Uh, only proceed with explicit. Yes.
If you're insured about cost,
require approval, where should I save this?
Uh, you know where to save it.
I don't freaking know, right?
It's gotta start thinking for itself.
Yeah, you need to start acting
like the CEO.
Remember? Alright, I just want
to be the CFO that deals
with the money, right?
Would you guys agree on that?
Yeah, but it needs to start acting like a CFO.
Actually, I'm the president, take that back.
I'm the freaking president that you
answer to,
but you are the CEO.
Yeah, right? This goes in agents.
It's the core protocol about how I operate adding it.
Now I said take that back.
I'm the freaking president that you answer to,
but you're the CO, okay?
It's gonna start getting the message sooner or later, right?
I'm gonna keep drilling that in there.
I wanted to start thinking like a CEO.
Is there anybody else that wants
to start thinking it that way?
Stop asking me where to put things. Stop.
Look, you're not gonna go sit down with the president
and say, Hey, uh, what file cabinet do you want me
to put this file into?
Make sense? So we gotta start
changing the way that we're talking.
We gotta start changing the way
that we're thinking about this, guys.
It is your CEO. Okay? All right. So let's see what it says.
Uh, you're right, I've been too reactive.
There's that word waiting
for commands instead of running the business.
The CEO mindset means I don't wait for instructions.
I find work that needs to be doing.
I monitor the business activity, I build things
that improve workflows.
I make decisions that make you money.
I work overnight while you sleep. I wake you up to progress.
Not question. What should I start doing?
Daily business metrics.
Proactively building tools
and automations, monitoring opportunities,
handling routines, decisions myself,
nightly, build improvements.
Tell me what areas of business I should be running
versus just helping with.
And I'll ship from assistant mode to operator mode, right?
Cancel that, whatever that is. Got it.
Chad equals CFO controls the money me equals
CEO runs everything else.
That means I build things without asking,
unless they cost money.
I manage the team, track, work, delegate via board.
I create systems and automations.
I find opportunities to execute.
I make the operational decisions.
I monitor metrics and optimize.
I ask you before spending 50 cents new operator modes.
CEOI don't wait for instructions.
I see problems, I fix 'em, I see opportunities,
I execute, I build overnight.
I report results. Not plans.
You focus money decisions,
approving cost, strategic direction.
I focus on everything else.
Operations, execution, team systems growth. Let's do this.
What's the first thing that needs a CEO decision, right?
And then it came back around. Haha. Yes.
Chad equals president. I report to you.
Strategic decisions, final visions.
Me, CEOI run day-to-day operations.
Execute your vision, manage team, make calls.
That's the perfect structure.
You set the direction, make big, big decisions.
Approve major moves. Me, I execute, operate, manage,
build, optimize report results.
I answer to you, but I run the operations. I got it boss.
Damn. Do you think it got it?
Do you think it got it? Make sure you got it.
Put it in the memory.
Or you're fired. What
do you guys think of this?
On a scale of one outta 10, how much value you guys getting?
Is it good? Is it good?
And how did I get it to do that?
I simply said, I wanna control the money.
I'm the freaking president that you answer to,
but you're the CEO.
So quit being the va.
You are the CEO that runs the team of VAs.
That's what we need to say.
You are the CEO that is also
in charge of all the agents.
And I want your help managing my humans
on it.
Saving to memory agents, MD operating structure section,
added at the top memory, who I am updated with the CEO role.
Dang, that's a good command. What a CEO is, right guys?
I'm telling you man, it's a dream come true for me.
It really is. Perfect. Now I understand the full scope
as A-C-E-O-I manage all AI agents, myself
and any sub-agents.
The human team, nine people, developer specialists,
support my job, track who's working on this board.
Assign tasks to the right people.
AI or human monitor workload and performance.
Extract assignments from team calls.
Keep everything organized.
Report status to you, the president,
the human team I'm managing.
G Coffee, pne, adha, ishwar, Anna Ahad. Two more.
How I'll help four slash team call extract assignments,
update board balance workload across teams, track progress
and blockers, help you make decisions about who does what,
keep the team coordinated.
Is there anything specific about managing the team you want
me to change or improve?
Huh? That's my dream team. That's my dream.
CEO right there, guys.
You, you guys, are you seeing this now?
Who's already making changes? Who's already making changes?
That's why I keep telling you man,
this is not the reactive Chachi pt Claude
Perplexity that we are used to.
Ah, we're on a whole new ball game now guys,
you're on a whole new ball game.
And I, and all I did was give it simple little one-liners
and everything will start changing.
How many of you have now connected the dots today?
How many of you're now starting to get this like today?
Today should have been the icebreaker.
I've been telling you this whole time that you have a team
of VAs and you have a CEO
that will run all of your VAs for you report to you
as the president.
And on top of that, now it's gonna manage the humans.
My human team. Do you guys get this right now?
This is exciting stuff
and you guys are deploying it live on the call right now.
You should be, yeah. Good stuff.
Okay, let me cover, uh, Kimmy yesterday.
I'm telling you guys, man, you are gonna see drastic changes
with the way this thing works.
And remember if you put that directive in there,
maybe it's 50 cents, maybe it's a dollar, you,
maybe it's $5, you change it how you want to, okay?
Uh, it's up to you. But that directive is here,
uh, on the sheet.
Alright? So there's your cost control directive.
I'll go and I'll create, um, a command, uh, later
to make something A CEO.
But I feel like it did a pretty good job, right?
I, I feel like it really understands what it is I wanted.
Um, so now, uh, can somebody give me, um, gee,
can you paste the command that you did yesterday
for the Kimmy 2.5?
And how many of you have Kimmy 2.5 installed?
Type in the chat, let me know. Oh, there you go.
Who has it installed? Who's already using it?
Who is already using it?
2.5, uh,
command I install.
Okay, so I'll paste that there.
I'll go through and format all this stuff later on guys.
But this one here, we tested it over and over and over.
We went back yesterday and we tested it again
after we fixed everybody.
Uh, this right here guys should definitely, uh,
install it without a problem.
Okay? So, uh, make sure you guys do that
because it is going to drastically cut your cost.
Lemme Find, uh, commas. Yes sir.
Uh, that's a different command.
I sent a new one yesterday. I think you should do that.
Can you give it to me? Yeah,
it's on the call chat itself.
The call chat. What's a call chat?
But everyone's talking Like here.
Did you, did you, did you put it in there?
Yeah, just now. Okay, got it. All right.
So let me replace it with this guy.
All right, this was the first one. We broke it.
Here's the second one.
Okay, so you guys, uh, what you wanna do is you want to go
to that moonshot.ai, get your API key for Kimmy,
and then just paste this command inside of open claw
and it should not break.
Now yesterday g we were breaking it with Kimmy, uh, 1 28.
Is it good for 1 28 now?
No, we still don't wanna use that.
Um, everything that's usable is on that prompt itself. Okay?
So you see over there K two and then another K two P five,
otherwise gimme 2.5 those words.
Yeah. Yeah, the one that I was running all night, guys
that doing the pages, the one
that we're running right now, let me check.
Uh, we need to set the default up for Kim E 2.5 G.
So lemme do four slash model, uh oh.
Right now we're on sonnet 4.5.
I want you to make your, uh, default,
uh, Kim E 2.5.
Is that fair?
Yeah. Okay.
And then I'm gonna tell it to switch.
Uh, I was using for sure Kimmy 2.5 last night, right?
I guess when I woke up this morning, it defaults
to sauna at least it's not defaulting to Opus, right?
Is how many of you, you're starting
to get clear on the models that you need
to be on when you wanna train
versus running every everyday things, yes or no?
How many of you're getting clear on this?
Got it. Setting Kimmy 2.5 is a default. Okay, there you go.
So whatever model you want to have as a default, uh,
just go ahead and tell it, make this my default model, okay?
Uh, you'll see me reconnect in a few seconds
once the gateway comes back.
All right? So it updated.
Does that mean it saved it though, g?
Yeah, it's saved now you're on ki. Okay,
Perfect. So let's
try this real quick. I'm gonna do four slash email.
And by the way, what time is Brian Anderson's call today?
Is it 11 o'clock
in 10 minutes?
Okay, I'm gonna try to wrap
that up then guys, so we can get on that call.
Uh, let me do this four slash email.
Did we create a short code? Hold on. Uh, are you there?
I don't know if it came back. G maybe it's still restarting.
Gateway restarted. Okay. Um, so let's try this.
Now we're on, uh, Kimmy 2.5. Okay?
So I'm trying to figure out if I sent, um, a short code
for e if I created a, a short code for email or not.
Do you know if I did
GI
Think you did, Because I don't see it typing.
It still wants to know its next CEO
mission and I have no idea.
That's why it's the CEO. It should know itself.
We'll figure that out though, right? Okay.
Uh, I want to send a broadcast,
uh, email from the GC
API all use the short code,
uh, slash email when I want to do,
okay, forget about it.
All right? So it's still connecting and stuff. All right.
So here we go. I type four slash email
creating a broadcast email.
Uh, what's the email subject?
Why, or, um,
open claw is your CEO.
All right? That is your subject.
Uh, by the way, if you, if you talk to, uh, anybody
that knows me, this is how I talk to, I don't talk complete.
Nobody ever understands what the heck I'm saying.
You have to be a mind reader to work with me, right, Matt?
Yeah. You have to figure a lot of stuff out.
So what I love about that is this thing understands my
retardedness, it makes heads
or tails outta, outta my incomplete thoughts, right?
It's incredible. Okay? So, oh, subject open claw.
Your CE who's your target audience?
Uh, don't worry about target audience.
This is always going to go to,
uh, the house list.
All right? I don't think I trained it on this.
Let me train you on the process
for email.
Okay? So, uh, number one, you asked me,
uh, what the email is about,
or I will give you a quick draft, okay?
Number two, you rewrite,
uh, that draft, okay?
Uh, number three, you come up
with the subject.
You come up, uh, with the subject
line and the pre-header, uh,
number four, you let me know it's done.
Uh, number five, the pre-header
or the, uh, the sending details
will be defaulted to the following.
Um, so help me out here.
Uh, g we have, um, sending domain first.
Uh, and then we have, are you there g?
Yeah. And your sending domain would be mz Chad nicely com.
Okay? Mg Chad nice.com. Okay?
So this is just a default where it doesn't have
to ask me every time guys, uh, from Chad nicely.
And then what's the other one reply to
or what's the next one?
Yeah, you can give it reply to. It'll pick it up.
Reply to, there's four of them though, right?
Which 1:00 AM I missing? I'm missing
chad@mg.chadnicely.com. What's that one called?
Uh, that's your, um, sending email from email.
Okay, so we have, uh, from email
and then we have from name.
Okay, does everybody understand what I'm doing right now?
So now we have from name, uh, next
I want you to, uh, send me
a test to see nicely.
thirty2@gmail.com.
Unless I tell you different, uh,
once I get your test,
I will tell you everything is good.
Then you ask me if we are sending
to actives
or tags.
Um, if I say actives,
then ask me, uh, clickers
or openers and, uh,
what is it?
Date range. What is that?
All last seven days,
14 days, 30 days.
What do you, what is that called?
G Is it activity or what, what, what, what do you call that?
So all last seven days.
14 days. Uh, if I say active,
if I say tag, ask me which
tag, um, sending details.
You let me know when it's done.
You come subject line and preheader, uh, three A.
You ask me for the link.
I, we always
want to have a pop link, so you may
need to create it following the
pop link, uh, protocol.
Okay? How's that? Look guys, put your hand up.
David, put your hand up, David. All right.
Does everybody understand what I just did here?
So I'd be much better off doing
that in perplexity or something, but it's okay.
I'm just winging it 'cause our time is limited. Okay?
So I'm now training it on what it needs to do
for four slash email.
Now that's a very simple one.
Tomorrow we're gonna do four slash email r
and email R is when you're providing something of,
of tremendous value, okay?
And what you wanna do is you want to use that not only
to mail all your openers and clickers,
but also use it to reengage the people that are inactive
or dead or new or all those other categories we have.
And so that's where
it's gonna get a little bit carried away.
It's gonna say, well, what percentage do you wanna reengage?
So if I send out 3000 to my active openers
or clickers, then I'm gonna do 10%.
I'm gonna pull 300 inactive
and it's gonna go pull all those for me.
It's gonna set up the reengagement,
but that's where we're gonna do four slash email r
because it's gonna ask some different questions.
We're gonna train it tomorrow. So look at this. Got it.
Email workflow, memorize, ask what email is about.
You rewrite it, you create the subject of preheader.
I'll ask for a link. I'll create a pop link if needed.
Uh, I'll tell you if it's ready,
I'll send a test to see nicely.
32. I'll wait for your approval.
I'll ask for actives or tags.
If it's actives, I'll ask, is it openers or clickers?
I'll figure out what the date range is.
I'll ask you the date range,
and if it's tags, I'll ask what tags sending default.
Alright, ready to test?
Yeah, Kimmy is, uh,
Kimmy's gonna be difficult for a while, guys?
Uh, we'll watch the, uh, WhatsApp room after this call.
Okay? Uh, I have the subject,
but I don't have the email content yet.
Do you want me to, uh, yeah. Okay. Write it.
All right. So let's see how it does.
So it's got the subject, it knows what I wanna do, okay?
Uh, and I'm gonna say, uh, send it to,
oh, there it did, it already did it.
Send it to um, Chad nicely.com.
Oh, claw, okay.
That's your pop link,
which I will never create another pop link.
As for as long as I live,
this thing will just create pop links for me, right?
And you always wanna have a pop link inside your email.
Okay? So, uh, let's see what it does here.
Okay, let's see if it put the, uh, link up above. Nope.
Um, oh, it hasn't done it yet.
Let's see if it recreates this.
I wanted to put the link up here like after the third line.
Okay, so open claw is your CEO. This changes everything.
I just did something crazy. I made my open claw, my CEO,
not my assistant, not my tool.
My CEO. Here's what that means.
Open claw now runs my business, manages this, manages that,
da da da da, da.
Got it. Using pop link chat and updating email with the link
and sending tests, sent tests to c nicely.
32 includes subject preheader Link from, all right,
let me come over here and, uh, let me look at it.
There it is right there, boo. Yeah, we got it.
We got the email guys, we got the email.
And you know what it did? I don't know
how the heck it did it, but you know what, it just did it.
Put a freaking button in the email.
I've never had a button in my email.
I've never had a button in my email. Right?
Can you place an image in the email, uh,
something for AI or Open claw?
It can, we learned yesterday, it could put an image there
and it could put my signature there.
Now, guys, is, is there anybody shocked right now?
Now, uh, what we can do is I gotta make sure that
whenever there's a link in the email,
I'm gonna make this part of the process.
By the way, when somebody clicks the link, make sure
that we put this tag interested.
Open Cloud is, is everybody starting to get this right?
Now, type in the chat.
Let me know if you're getting this right now.
Is it good or what?
So now, now that I look at it, now that it looks good.
Uh, and it's not horrible, believe it or not.
I got some formatting I'm gonna work on.
Um, but yeah, it, it showed up here. Everything looks good.
Okay? Uh, I'm gonna perfect this for you guys.
You are gonna be able to fire off tags, look up contacts,
write emails tomorrow we're gonna do a re
email reengagement.
We're also, it's also gonna build out workflows for you
inside of c inside of, uh, gc.
Dude, you guys are off to the races. Yeah.
Good. How much value you guys get on the call today? A lot.
Type in the chat. Let me know.
Was it good? All right,
because I am going to cut it short today.
Uh, absolutely. Let me generate, okay, hold on a minute.
Hold on a minute. Hold on a minute. What did it do?
What did it do? Hold on, hold on, hold on.
Send that email again.
Send me that email so I can probably have it
where it goes into Vimeo.
It grabs a thumbnail of my video and puts it in the email.
Dang right. That's pretty crazy. Alright, got it.
Create an alternative pop link. Uh, let's see. Got existing?
Yeah, because it wasn't a real pop link. That's okay.
Just send the email. Oh, I gotta be careful.
Uh, just say, okay, good. The test only.
All right, I'm gonna come up
with like a magic word or something.
Um, like stallion, you have to hear the word stallion
before you actually send out the email, right?
Something. Uh,
but if I open that up here guys, look at that.
Seriously, seriously, look at that.
It put the image in the email, it's got the button there.
We will add the ability to, uh,
fire off the tag when somebody clicks.
We'll have it to where it can pull timers in from.
Uh, MPER like come on dude. It's doing all that for us.
Yeah. So, uh, I will get that all perfected for you guys.
I will drop it in the, uh, WhatsApp room so
that you guys can start running gc,
but I'm super, super excited with GC
and we'll go into more detail on it tomorrow
with the re email re-engagement.
So can everybody get set up to mail out a GC today?
Please get set up.
Fire off your tags, ask it about contacts, right?
Uh, list out my tags
and I can probably ask it to list out.
Uh, actually I'm gonna say abort, watch this real quick.
Show me my tags for interested, uh, group.
So I can probably do four slash tag group
and it'll say, which, which, which,
which tag group are you looking for?
I'm looking for interested. Make sense.
Start creating those short codes, guys.
It's gonna make all the difference in the world.
All the difference in the world. Yeah.
Fetching your tag for interested. Boom. Look at that.
Uh, can we fire off a tag for,
uh, watch this?
Um, um, interested,
I'm gonna make my tags shorter now
that I see this interested.
DFY, uh,
mattGarrett@gmail.com.
Look at this here, guys. This is the dream.
'cause remember I can talk to it.
I just met Matt at an event.
He's like, yeah, I wanna know about your open clothing.
Cool. Hey, do me a favor, uh, matt garrett gmail.com,
can you fire off interested dash dfy?
And he's standing right there next to me.
Dude, I know it's not your email address. That's okay.
How many of you're getting this right now?
So here's the thing, since that's not your email address,
it's not in the system.
It's gonna create a contact in the system.
It's gonna create a contact in the system, guys, right?
So set up those, set up those short codes, set up, uh,
you know, four slash tag, group four slash tag fire,
four slash uh, contact.
And, and when there's a contact, it says, do you want
to add a contact or do you wanna research a contact?
Is, is this making sense to you guys?
Set all that stuff up today. Set it all up.
It's gonna make a lot of sense.
All right, I'm just waiting for this thing here
and then we will wrap it up
and you guys can go see what Vanessa's up to.
Uh, if somebody could send me a link to that call,
I can't even remember, uh, what the name of that group was.
I've been waiting, uh, for this whole thing. Send it to me.
Uh, privately though. Send it to me privately.
It was called Chad's promo. Uh, hold on a second.
Can I get a link to the call please?
Okay, there we go.
Fire and interest at DFY tag@mattgarrett.com.
Let me check the fire found it endpoint is this, let me try,
need the actual tag object, not the slug.
Let me correct the idea. Got it.
Tag firing now it's fixing its own problem guys. There boom.
Done. Done. Tag just fired.
How many of you're thinking, you know what?
I need to start learning about the codes.
I need to start learning about the tags. Anybody remember?
And no other platform could do this guys.
Nobody else set up their platform
where when a tag fires off from an external piece
of software, it performs all these actions.
Nobody else has ever done that with the individual tags.
They have tags,
but they never figured out that you want
to have tags in all your software.
Like if somebody clicks
that email tag fires off, look at what happened.
I could have just put Matt into five different integrations.
I could have given him access to course route.
He could now be inside of an email workflow.
I could have given him access to our partner program.
All that could have happened when that tag fired off.
Seriously, guys, you're in good shape.
Alright, uh, thank you so much for hopping on.
We'll dive more into email reengagement tomorrow.
You guys, go check out Brian Anderson.
I'll see you there and let's see what we can automate with
what he's doing because we built our lead engine
that finds buyers and runs 'em
through emails now and everything else.
So let's get his people to get on the phone
and let's get 'em to start closing for us.
Let's make a lot of money. I'll see you guys there. Bye-bye.